name said Franklin ahead of elite
performance I'm ed Clark I'm the lead
nutritionist here reading Football Club
the league that we're in is Unforgiven
you know what we do nutrition will
underpin more how you can perform and
how you can train don't eat right you
can't train like the can't train right
you can't play right so to really
nutrition is the foundations of how you
develop as a footballer and how you can
perform on a Saturday Christmas it's
it's very busy you know we end up having
to two or three games in a week our main
focus is really kicking into that
recovery period it's crazy also set the
to slightly Tuesday you know the key for
us is is just ensuring that especially
after games you know they're getting
their recovery shape great source of
protein in there great source of carbs
it just starts it's not that recovery in
descending and then also that we load
them up in the right way leading into
the next day which can there be anything
from 48 to 72 hours later it's a tough
period we kind of push high carb meals
quite a lot of the time high protein
content of almost everything that they
have to take in because they're not
preparing for one game they're
recovering from the rich from the last
supplements become pivotal at this time
of year we've pushed that food first
kind of mentality and everything that we
do here you know some of the highest
quality in terms of food but those
little supplements we use to make the
difference between just like a normal
kind of training we can this this busy
period we have to make sure that every
day like you're seeing this morning
nutritionists are in there getting
everything set up for the players as
they come in the building you know first
and foremost they're coming in getting
their water taking their tablets
whatever they need to do on the best
boat basis some players have different
needs and that's what we can recently
that with science the sport
the main things that we do to combat
injury is just to keep that protein
intake nice and high and then it's the
other kind of additional little
supplements that we also try to fit in
there trying to fight off the colds and
flus that they're so abundant at this
kind of time of year I mean use science
to support heads purely because it's
such good products the immune tablet
that they've just started doing out
there lads enjoy the taste of it do they
get you know they want to be vibrated
from it they get that little boost of it
and see and and the iron in it and it's
that's gone down really well with them
the amount of muscle injuries that we
get as well from from training or from
games and people getting knocks and that
kind of thing obviously it's not gonna
cure it but if someone's got a nice high
protein intake that's gonna give their
body everything that they need to repair
those muscles then then that some of
what we can do is nutritionists or
sports scientists it's so easy to break
down and crumble this time of year in
you know a week out you can miss three
games and that's they're so important
we've gotta make sure that again
everything is nailed on it's there's one
percent we don't have the biggest squad
in the league so we've gotta make sure
that players we do have that we've got
to turn out you know three times a week
or in the best possible condition they
can be and that their fuel to the right
levels
[Music]
you
you